police in central Virginia are searching  this morning for two people that were  swept away by a flash flood their car  was caught in a rush of water last night  in Albemarle County that's near the city  of Charlottesville in Western North  Carolina a massive mudslide is blamed  for destroying a home and killing two  people inside police say that this house  collapsed because of a gas leak caused  by the landslides recent heavy rain  caused several mudslides and serious  flooding in the area east of Asheville  evacuation orders were lifted after  engineers determined that a nearby dam  hit by a landslide was indeed safe and  not at risk of failing more rain is  expected later this week